no let me put you in a mansion dancing I
recently found out which sounds like
it's not a like a mind-blowing thing but
I recently found out that squatting or
kneeling is better for your health
because it requires more muscle activity
than sitting on a chair I believe that
that's why Asians live longer huh
wanting and gentle eyes [ __ ] dull
like what all Asian squad this way oh
you can squat so like you would do that
while you're like eating or what like
squatting in general like just forever
just bet you the status city yeah oh so
we just we're supposed to just do that
instead of legs of sitting there
kneeling can you do it cuz those people
who can't do it I can do it you know
your new your heels come up I mean it
hurts like [ __ ] you start the building
yeah
to squat for a long time yeah you make a
news all squatting I'm right here
because there's so much easier to sit
that's why all opposed to take poops oh
yeah like I'm never going I can normally
timeline today what's it about for you
to its vanity just vanity
no for me I just feel like it's just
it's better for me I don't know yeah for
me I want to plant two feet firmly on
the side and just shoot it out like
that's what I wanna shoot it out
caboose squatty potty but whenever I go
to somebody I like the feeling of it
going yeah it's gross it goes out this
good and you feel like you was like man
I'm gonna run out of space in this
commode you look like I've taken some
fools where it felt like it was a
[ __ ] hey a-hole - but it doesn't
shoot out yeah anime put words swirls
leaves the most residue in your guy's
hole when you're wiping oh really no no
it cuz it goes and then there's nothing
there I'll just bring the water holes in
and not just lift one leg up and I just
can I can I please preach about the the
bidet religion please yes I will back
you because I love it I feel like
everyone should get up a day because
every poop is a one white poop and
there's a jet that if you just just
relax your butthole a little bit it
gives you like a small enema or the
board head yeah and then you and then
you just push it all out and everything
that's stuck in there comes out here's
my thing with that I would get spoiled
with it and never feel like I should use
a bathroom squirting to my butt cept my
husband not even a boyfriend yeah you
gotta wait that's not nice it's a Maya
Angelou quote no love is so I ever walk
out of us of a porta potty right and I
looked at this guy who's about to go in
there and I'm like it's a porta potty
dude like it's on me you know I'm saying
well like there's this there's this
feeling like when I was in the porta
potti where I was like for some reason I
feel like I can get everything out what
I can smell every [ __ ] [ __ ] so you're
like no there's no shame in here man
it's just like fully like I'm fully open
to do whatever I feel the exact opposite
because of the fact that it's smell so
disgusting and everything around me
feels like
[ __ ] on the walls and everything you're
just trying to do it you do it you tell
me you don't feel like it's like it's a
unity no I like nordstrom bathroom where
it's like floor-to-ceiling doors and I
feel like no one knows who where I am
yeah
Tim you weren't girl oh we went to the
porta potti in the manag bathroom the
first porta potti we find all this like
that we were like ah [ __ ] like we'll be
in there holding each other's kneecaps
and stuff like don't touch it sis and
don't like you gotta help reduce yeah I
had to hold her like that oh really the
facial expression is the most accurate
thing I think he's like facial
expression evoke up troubled it's a true
experience I remember I was on an
airplane once and I was waiting for the
bathroom and this dude comes out and I
walk in and I swear to god it was like
the devil came and used this guy's
butthole as his vessel it was the most
disgusting [ __ ] [ __ ] I've ever
smelled in my life I was offended and
the thing is he walked out he even
looked at me and then just walked away
and don't courtesy flush should just
burn a night I think it's a form of
exhibitionism when you know that there's
a line outside and you take a big fat
[ __ ] and then you look at them and you
don't flush afterwards that's
exhibitionist you know it is it's like I
guess what I own you a little bit
somebody your shits about the equivalent
and showing somebody your balls I think
she was saying like the courtesy flush
so it doesn't smell as potent you you
leave out bro leave it it in there come
on imagine you're in line somebody pops
ahead I'll know I came in do you want me
to flush this oh oh yes yes when there's
a line or like when you get in there
someone had just come out there was no
line before you like and then you come
out and there's a line but it was there
[ __ ] use that people yeah but you can't
explain like I will I just feel that was
already in here just so you know hey
that happens your did you get office I'm
like I don't [ __ ] here I've never seen
here one time we know the culprits right
oh yeah we know yeah some people they do
something
the toilet seat up they don't [ __ ]
replenish the toilet paper it's the
worst job you know who sit in this chair
like to linger a little bit no a poop
oasis and the thing is is that both
[ __ ] offices are like this both the
offices got bidets multiple air
freshener doesn't oh really
no bring the bidets from the new yet and
fridge
whoever kate whoever decorated and set
this office up had pooping in mind this
person said every morning I'm gonna come
in there and I'm gonna [ __ ] well shower
yeah so they usually leave their houses
and go [ __ ] at JK offices we also had a
JK meeting where they're like hey
whatever you guys want
we'll figure it out and I was like get
the [ __ ] fridge from the [ __ ] new
office brings this office and then they
broke it to me that they couldn't figure
it out for whatever the [ __ ] weeds
anomaly I think or something whatever
put it in the [ __ ] back with the
costumes of the ghosts back there he'll
take care of it well there's a whole
part of the office that never sees the
light of day right but nobody is like
hey let's troubleshoot to that level
everyone's like yeah I didn't fit in the
old [ __ ] fridge space so that means
it doesn't work well they tried Steve
wall but it's true bernie is hard cuz
they you gotta get upstairs borders big
ass truck and mostly friends yeah part
has no excuses at all true his friends
are [ __ ] barbell B barbell is in that
office they could deallocate that for
you yes they just don't want to because
they want the fridge that's being honest
a moment it's all again Steve I know
what it's like I always like to love
something you love a fridge I love that
fridge - did you cover the fridge maybe
we'll be given new fridge in our house
we could give our old fridge I'm in I'm
getting rid of my fridge but it's going
to someone who wants it so I can't come
here so think Steve was a pretty bad man
like you would have one of those
frigerators that talked to you oh girl
I'm getting one that has a carrying Cup
in it and it ones are bad right I know
the plastics it knows oh I know but like
you know baby
no but Ernest will die in it oh listen
to me we use the reusable ones yeah
their own coffee in their happy but we
also have a disposable burns in case
we're in a rush okay sorry it's fine oh
good god why the turtles are flying
turtles [ __ ] live I've been around
for thousands of years I haven't figured
out how to [ __ ] avoid plastic Turtles
outlive us leave us like a [ __ ]
there's 200 year old turtle he's like
he's seen it all though plastic what is
that hey what the Turtles life
expectancy compared to a human right
okay smoke on the water
no the turtle should be telling us what
to do yeah give me a Spencer that don't
get it
turtles don't smoke they don't drink
they don't wait okay guys I didn't even
tell you the rest of the night oh my god
yeah like six rivers blows perfect
timing
okay so there were these findings that
are based on data gathered from a
hunter-gatherer population in ten z10
Tanzania Tanzania sorry so this
population they weren't devices that
measured their physical activity as well
as their periods of rest and they found
that despite being sedentary for almost
ten hours every day they still did not
show signs of the physical deterioration
that's like you know people like us in
like normal civilizations see in our
bodies because when we're sitting we use
a lot less muscles than what they do
which is squatting what are you oh my
god I'm sorry I was listening really
intently the whole time cuz I forgot
what the article was and I was like any
second there's gonna be a key word here
nevermind to me exactly what he did it
comes to the end she says squatting I
was like that's it you did not have to
call yourself out
so they're saying that despite the fact
that they're still being sedentary they
are squatting using some muscles
internally that just leave them to be
healthier overall than us I should do
that while I'm streaming Jeana if you
come into your stream and you're sitting
here you're like alright guys we're
gonna play some apex but you trying to
be like I'm gonna be looking for the
only fans link I'm like crazy dude
that's not even sexy that I look like an
old cat whose mom do it with some moose
or sawdust and leg as I guarantee you
watch it go up Lou so I can get a little
piece like that was so specific that was
a thing there was a girl shorts with
leggings
there was a girl one time they got
banned on stream because she had some
really loose street shorts on and a lip
fell out Oh a full unlit fell out and I
mean it was like how did she get like
this close to shake it loose it
literally just fell out she was doing
something and she just wrapped the leg
basically around the cameras I know it
was some of y'all saw that she later she
had a whole lip fall out and it was a
whole thing they banned her because they
said it was intentional and I was like I
think that that lip just fell out see if
the thing is it doesn't work for Asians
because look like it's not sexy in any
way because like I said if I squat I'm
also because in Asia there's a lot of
squat toilets so just I would suck in I
would just look like a [ __ ] asian
grandmother just like would look like my
chopsticks and [ __ ] doesn't work that
way it's not sexy guys can jerk off -
yeah I could talk to a chick shaking a
[ __ ] hot sauce ball
yeah the bandanna jack off to like like
play boys that's Little Leaguer paper
object off when I was a kid I remember
jacking off to the the drawn figure on
it
exactly box like what yes I do I do
kidding that piece of paper turns off
trouble
yes you'll understand she's sitting
there and you can see her fingers she
does this another thing I was like Salah
me my mom got the Victoria Secret
catalog
it was like I found the [ __ ] Book of
Mormon I was like wow this is a whole
religion I didn't understand and now I
find it and it's beautiful if the
prophet has told me you know there's
like boys where if they get grounded
they'll jerk off to like a lamp a lamp
titty oh yeah it's just a little lamp up
top this British guy and yet I respect
them they're there where they came first
we stand those souls of Jack yeah they
did comfort
[Music]
[Music]